okay we're live we are waiting for
Donald Trump's live address to the
nation he has been touting a major
announcement for for a while at this
point and initially scheduled for 3:00
p.m. Eastern today then rescheduled for
4:00 p.m. Eastern and we're about a half
hour from that and we'll be talking
about what might we expect from this
address I do want to hear from people in
the audience we are going to maybe open
up the phone lines after the address
depending on how long it is a lot going
on and a lot to discuss so welcome to
everybody I'm here it's a weekend I'm in
the studio I have my David Pakman show
coffee in my David Pakman show coffee
mug which I never do any product
placement of our own stuff and I really
should delicious absolutely delicious
use the Chemex to make it it's all
available on our website david
pakman.com slash gear and i'll be
sipping it throughout the more Trump
lies the more caffeinated I think I'm
going to be today okay so let's start
with what to expect
one quote by the way one cool thing
super chat is on and I've set up a shot
here where I can actually put the super
chats on screen as they come in this is
the last I guess we would call event
that would be displayed in the super
chat window which was Pamela burger
becoming a david pakman show YouTube
member last night so anyway as super
chats come in I'll be able to pop them
up on the screen there which is which is
very cool let's talk about what we are
to expect today a CNN article outlining
what it is that we might be seeing today
President Donald Trump expected to
propose extending protections for daca
recipients and individuals with
temporary protected status in exchange
for border wall funding in his remarks
Saturday afternoon this is based on a
senior administration official and a
source familiar with the matter
who confirmed this to CNN it will be at
4 p.m. as I mentioned so to reset the
context here is that Donald Trump wants
to build a wall with Mexico
he said Mexico would pay for it of
course they were never going to pay for
it now we know that now he wants you to
pay for it and he said he would shut
down government if he doesn't get the
money from taxpayers through our elected
officials to pay for it he didn't get it
and he shut it down that's where we are
now we're now close to entering the
fifth week of the shutdown 800,000
government employees haven't been paid
millions of contractors impacted Airport
safety impacted etc etc etc so where we
now find ourselves is that Donald Trump
is increasingly desperate he's desperate
to get something that he could call a
victory of sorts on the record and that
is why now we are hearing here is a
compromise that Donald Trump may propose
at the top of the hour which would
include in exchange for getting that 5.7
billion for the wall getting a giving
some protections to daca recipients now
there's two sort of main lines of
thought that I have here that I would
want to sort of throw out there let's
start with the one that suggests
Democrats should just go with it okay
let's start with that one and then we'll
talk it through and see if it's if it
makes any sense to us if you are of the
mindset that the wall isn't really going
to be built because as I've mentioned
before 5.7 billion would cover just a
tiny fraction of it it would take a very
long time to even really get started
that even if you give Trump the money on
paper he's not going to be able to
actually do much before he's no longer
president even if he's president for six
more years with just 5.7 billion a
reasonable position might be if you can
get stuff from Trump you wouldn't
otherwise do like concessions on daca
for 5.7 billion that quite frankly he's
not going to be able to do much with
maybe you do it and then everybody sort
of quote wins in the sense that if you
don't want the
all 5.7 billion for it isn't really
gonna get you much of a wall if you do
want some concessions on Dhaka you get
them from Trump that is one position
okay the reason that I'm skeptical of
the idea that Democrats should just take
what they can get because ultimately
Trump might get his money anyway without
any concessions is that what you have to
understand on Dhaka is that this is not
saying daca recipients get a path to
citizenship okay I would actually be
much more willing to negotiate if I was
on the Democratic side of the table if
you were saying well 5.7 billion for the
wall 5.7 which won't build much and can
just be the entire project can be
stopped by the next president anyway 5.7
billion in exchange for an actual path
to citizenship for daca recipients and a
bunch of other stuff
maybe we actually have something to talk
about but what you have to remember is
it's political suicide for Republicans
to start deporting daca recipients it it
there are a lot of things that Donald
Trump can do and he would get away with
with very little punishment or political
consequence but for Republicans and
Trump to start deporting daca recipients
remember who came to the United States
when they were underage many still are
not adults because their parents came to
the United States they that that would
be a major political blunder so it's not
that the choices either you do this deal
or Trump will start deporting daca
recipients it's it's very different than
that it's if you don't do this deal
Trump's not going to deport doctor daca
recipients he might threaten to he might
try to get other things in exchange for
not deporting them but they're not going
to deport daca recipients because even
Republicans Marco Rubio many Republicans
understand that's political suicide the
other point is that's not even what's
being offered here this is if we based
on what we're being told right based on
the CNN article about about what's being
offered here or what what is expected to
be offered here we're talking about an
extension for that status that the
protected status that daca recipients
have so when you consider
that we're not talking about a path to
citizenship and that in either case
Trump's not going to start deporting
daca recipients Republicans aren't going
to start deporting daca recipients it
becomes much more questionable to me
whether this is a deal that Democrats
should be making we're predicting right
because we haven't yet actually seen
what it is Donald Trump is going to
propose the CNN article we're looking at
also adds the compromise proposal would
allow immigrants covered by TPS some of
whose protections Trump has rescinded to
remain in the country the senior
administration official told CNN that
this proposal remains fluid and could
change Democrats were not consulted on
this and have rejected similar overtures
in the past it's clearly a Republican
and Republican negotiation a Democratic
congressional aide said what other
interesting information do we have here
source familiar with the discussion says
that Trump cast Jared Kushner and Mick
Mulvaney and Mike Pence to try to craft
something here not exactly people that
we would consider the best negotiators
the most effective political operatives
Trump now has been consulted to get him
on board I've already read one op-ed
piece which claims that Democrats are
not going to go for this but again
before you can actually reject or
approve anything you have to see what
the proposal is we are waiting for
Donald Trump at the top of the hour just
how far are we from that about 22
minutes so the plan for the live stream
I believe is going to be because we are
really live right now I will take super
chat questions and comments until the
top of the hour and then we will go to
the live speech from Donald Trump and
then if people want me to open up the
phone lines after for reactions and all
of that other stuff then we will if we
get 10 new members at david pakman.com
slash membership i will open up the
phone lines as soon as trump's address
is done and we might actually have some
time for a bunch of calls and for a lot
of people to get in today because we do
have the the the speech is expected to
be relatively short so to coupon codes
are on the table today for
memberships you can use the coupon code
this is 20 20 it'll chopped 40% off of
the cost of a membership membership is
mostly how we're funded it's how we have
staff and a studio and do all of the
stuff we do and have now access to a
great quiet 24/7 studio so that I can do
weekend's streams and bring you live
breaking news like what we're expecting
now so coupon code number one is this is
2020 the other coupon code that's
available is 2019 to zero one nine that
will drop a $60 membership for the year
we're talking about for the year now to
just $20.19 so if we get just ten
members it doesn't matter what you pay
it doesn't matter if it's monthly or
yearly if we get 10 new members during
the stream as soon as Donald Trump's
address is over I will open up the phone
lines I have the system ready to go the
number will be six one seven eight three
zero
4750 but that's if people actually want
that and and if people don't if we don't
get any membership signups then then we
don't have to worry about it no big deal
we won't we won't take calls
let me get now to the Super chats and
see what's going on I'm now able to
display Super chats on screen the first
is from mr. Segura with a dollar
ninety-nine saying thank you for doing
these streams truly my pleasure
um one of the great things about having
now not only our own studio 24/7 which
is not being shared with any other shows
but having a place that's actually quiet
remember our old studio not only when we
were doing the show but if we wanted to
do something after hours or on the
weekends the amount of construction
noise that we were dealing with was
oppressive to say the least so we don't
we're not dealing with that anymore
Chris Dini has sent the $2 super chat no
question or comment very much appreciate
it razzamatazz has sent a twenty two
Norwegian kroner super chat I believe
that's what n okay is I don't know how
much that is in u.s. dollars I would
guess it's five because or two I'm not
I'm not really sure but I appreciate it
either way in 22 say it sounds like a
like a big number
Jason Prevot with a $5 super shot keep
up your objective nature
David thank you I think every time this
comes up when I sometimes will get
praise from people and I might seem like
a praise obsessed narcissist sometimes
or maybe not maybe maybe I don't that
would be great if I don't but I don't
just welcome any praise sometimes people
will write in and say David I love your
show because it's not biased and that is
actually a red flag to me because our
show is very politically biased in the
sense that it is a left-wing progressive
show we're not a neutral show but I try
to be objective in all of the stories
that we cover let's see what else we
have here Jenny Locke Jenny Locke says
can you explain what's going on with
BuzzFeed and Trump yeah so we're going
to cover this on we're gonna cover this
on Monday BuzzFeed news put out an
article which claimed that Michael Cohen
told Robert Muller under oath and that
there are supporting documents emails
other documents about this that Donald
Trump directed him to lie to Congress
about the backstory of Trump Tower
Moscow if that's true if that were true
that would be the first sort of direct
under oath testimony and records that
tell us Muller has been told
Trump committed the felony of directing
witnesses to lie to Congress that would
be obstruction of justice it's actually
almost identical to what Richard Nixon
ultimately resigned for in the 1970s
resigned over in the 1970s it would be
witness tampering and it could signal
the beginning of the end for Trump
however about 24 hours after that
BuzzFeed news story broke
Robert Mulder's spokesperson put out a
statement and you have to really I don't
have it in front of me we could maybe
get into this after Trump's Trump's
address today after the after 24 hours
went by a robert muller spokesperson put
out a statement saying that the
characterization of what was in that
report is not accurate and that it is
not precise with regard to statements
that have been made to the office of the
special counsel so when that happened
the write immediately said
it's fake news the entire thing is fake
nothing in the BuzzFeed news story is
true the problem is that that also
appears not to be an accurate assessment
of the molar statement because when you
go back and look at the specificity and
vocabulary in the molar statement you
see that there they're not saying that
the spirit of the story is untrue
they're saying that some of the specific
characterizations of testimony are not
accurate so we I don't really know the
truth of the matter right now the
article in BuzzFeed news cited
statements to the special counsel is
only one type of evidence purporting to
demonstrate Donald Trump directed Cohen
to lie to Congress they claim to have
emails they claim to have other other
documents so we'll see it is remember
BuzzFeed news and BuzzFeed are not the
same thing okay so it is very difficult
for me to imagine that BuzzFeed news
would just invent that federal federal
government sources told them this
there's no upside to that and ultimately
they would end up extraordinarily
embarrassed they are saying they stand
by the story so hopefully by our next
show on on Monday I will have more more
information about that okay
let me take another sip of my David
Pakman show coffee here Boult 9000 has
sent a 10 Canadian dollar super chap
asking how should we deal with
mischaracterization of progressive
values for example liver liberals or
violent regressive and Tifa SJW
anti-free speech etc well there's two I
mean when you say how should we deal
with it as individuals we should make
sure that we don't commit acts of
violence that we don't suppress speech
and all of that stuff I mean right that
that that's a sort of general thing when
you say we as maybe the progressive
movement more broadly you need to
explain what really is going on and not
allow those narratives to persist so
we've done long-form pieces on our
program about those mischaracterizations
we've talked about the free speech issue
the idea of violence being on the left
it's not it's mostly on the political
right you just you can't you can't
relent
when it
comes to that debar new has sent a to
Canadian dollar super chat thank you
very much you know it's risky for me to
put up super chats like this because a
super chat could come up where maybe
someone tells me that I should debate
somebody and maybe I don't want that to
appear on screen if you know what I mean
and I wouldn't be able to control that
I'd have to like very erratically switch
back to myself fullscreen or something
like that so there's a real risk to
putting this up fullscreen Dan Campbell
with the ten dollar super chat should
Democrats immediately begin impeachment
hearings to educate ready the public for
impeachment pending Moeller report as
was done in Watergate
I don't think so Dan no because here's
the problem the circumstances right now
are very different than than during
Watergate in the 1970s the facts of what
is going on with Trump are different
although some of the crimes may end up
being the same ones but you right now
have a 24/7 media cycle right wing media
cycle an apparatus that defends the
president no matter what all the time
where an advance or preparatory
impeachment merely to educate the public
is not a good idea I think what is
important is to remind the public at
every opportunity when we say impeaching
the president we're not talking about
the removal of the president impeachment
is the process started by the House of
Representatives ultimately the Senate
votes on whether to adjudicate the
impeachment proceedings with a removal
of the president impeaching the
president means we believe that things
have taken place that warrant the
beginning of those proceedings that is
not we are removing the president there
is still a process by which that would
be evaluated okay let me say thank you
to a few new members and patrons and
we're looking for 10 new members and
patrons in order to open up the phone
lines after Trump's top of the hour
speech brandon tizzle or tizzle is a new
member at david pakman.com drake jensen
is a new member at david pakman.com and
daniel lapel is a new patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show yeah
I will do either so whether you do a
membership or sign up on patreon we're
looking for 10 new supporters during the
stream and then I
open up the phone lines at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty so
either way counts were thirty percent of
the way there with Drake Daniel and
Brandon so regular rates apply or you
can use the coupon code
this is twenty twenty to say forty
percent or you can use the coupon code
2019 to get a yearly membership for just
$20.19 thirty percent of the way there
and we'll open I look forward to opening
up the phone lines and seeing what's on
people's minds after this top of the
hour speech from Trump Roy Earle with
the ten dollar super chat David isn't it
funny that Trump stirs were against the
Iran deal but overlooked his business
investment in Azerbaijani hotel that had
connections with Revolutionary Guards
keep up the work from Canada Roy that's
way too nuanced to I mean what you're
saying is just not even going to
register with the average trumpets
you're pointing out one of the probably
hundreds if not more hypocrisy and
double standards that exist within the
sphere of what is Trump but that is
that's unfortunately going to be very
very lost on the average trumpets razor
X with a two dollar super chat I feel
safe knowing you're watching this with
us well I can't bring you any safety
razor but I will bring you the best
analysis that I can and then hopefully
create hopefully we'll be able to as
people say engage in a open discussion
of ideas and let the best ideas kind of
float to the top like the fat on whole
milk or something like that I don't know
marc-eddy Adi with a four dollar $0.99
super chat if Democrats take the house
take the White House and Congress in the
future should we abolish the filibuster
to pass progressive legislation I've
talked about that before I'm open to
that idea but what you have to remember
is much like with court packing any
strategy that Democrats can successfully
use when they're in control can backfire
when they're not and in the same way
that you know when when the right says
we should kind of reinterpret the Bill
of Rights to eliminate birthright
citizenship they
are opening up a dangerous can of worms
by saying that the Bill of Rights is
open to reinterpretation along the same
lines Democrats should be very very
careful about which tactics they use and
in fact I spoke with we did an interview
with Dean Cameron Chemerinsky sorry not
Jaron Chemerinsky from UC Berkley School
of Law this week and he is the second
most cited legal scholar period and he
indicated that while he's not against
packing the court that you shouldn't
even be talking about it when it's not
something you can do because it just
gives the other side ideas and that's
sort of where I am on the elimination of
the of the filibuster 72 ganache sends a
25 Norwegian kroner super chat no
question or comment thank you very much
I appreciate that Mike 101 3 1994 with a
$20 super chat today's high super Chad
are you familiar with Stowe be face I
have no idea what that is
I don't know I'm not sure I don't know
what that is I apologize Stowe be face I
could have just said something horribly
racist for all I know Stowe be faces
something racist or it's a kid's cartoon
I I just I have not no idea and I
couldn't tell you what it is we are
under 10 minutes from Donald Trump's top
of the hour major announcement and as it
has been billed I'm drinking david
pakman show coffee I should drink it
more quickly because it's getting a
little cold
but it's not you know that in between
temperature where it's supposed to be
hot coffee but it's not super hot but
it's way too warm for your brain to
interpret it as iced coffee I'm about
probably 10 degrees above where we're
gonna get to that point so I'll sip a
little more frequently we are taking
super chats I will open up the phone
lines after the stream if we get 10 new
supporters via membership or patreon
during the stream and we have just been
crushing it lately with 20 30 40 new
supporters we're at 3 so far and
actually no we are now at 4
Robin loose Laos lows not sure how to
pronounce that Robin I'm confident
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership making robin the fourth new
member of the stream so let's let's just
get six more new members or patrons in
the next eight minutes or during the
speech and then right when we're done
with Trump's nonsense
we will do analysis and then open up the
phone lines I think that that's uh I
think it's a delightful plan and I look
forward to being able to do that let's
see what other super chats we have here
so Toby face I don't know what that is
let's see what's next here Elly Elly
well II L well with the $10 super chat
no deal for the wall if it's just an
extension of Dhaka and TPS Protection
Bridge Act Democrats must insist on a
real pathway to citizenship or No Deal I
tend to agree with ul because as I
pointed out if you're talking about five
billion for a tiny piece of the wall
some fraction of which will just replace
existing border fence in exchange for a
true a bonafide path the citizenship for
daca recipients we might actually have
something to talk about because that
would be a massive massive victory for
the left if what Trump is saying is
he'll just extend protections for
another period of time with no real path
to citizenship remember it's mostly an
empty threat that Trump and Republicans
are going to start deporting daca
recipients because it would be
politically extraordinarily destructive
so I tend to agree that I'm open to
negotiation but it has to be for
something more than just a temporary
extension of protections Sean Smith with
the ten dollar super chat if McDonald's
is made with a substantial amount of soy
products does that make Trump a soy boy
I at this point I don't even know what
is going on at McDonald's I haven't been
to a McDonald's in something like I want
to say it's been almost 18 years or so
since I've been to a McDonald's other
than the one near Washington Square Park
in New York City where once I did go in
and use their bathroom when I lived in
New York City but otherwise I didn't
know I don't know what's going on at
McDonald's biz Wiz with a $4 99-cent
super chat Dems should offer him a roll
of chicken wire come on
we all know this isn't the national
emergency it's about Trump's ego yeah so
that's one caveat if Donald Trump pulls
out the Declaration of a national
emergency during the speech that we're
waiting for at the top of the hour then
indeed we that change that then it's not
an in good faith negotiation at all then
it almost becomes secondary what it is
Trump's willing to offer because it's
the total misuse of the the mechanism of
national emergency X sends a $5 Super
chat what non-political YouTube channels
and videos do you watch your show is
excellent keep it up i watch really
weird stuff i watch a bunch of chess
streamers like Eric Rosen and John
Bartholomew and Ben Feingold and a bunch
of others I hate kuru Nakamura i watch
cooking channels like eater has some
awesome series on sushi which are just
really entertaining all watch old
jacques pepin cooking videos I'm all
over the place I'm I couldn't even you
would be shocked if you saw what I was
watching let's take a look at how long
we have we got about five minutes until
this thing gets underway so plenty of
time to get a few more super chats in
there before I do I want to say thanks
to hey soos Lopez and David Ruiz which
gets us to six out of ten new members
okay I said at the top of the stream if
we get ten new members or patrons during
the stream the phone lines will go wide
open after Trump's speech at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
we are 60% of the way there so for new
subscribers or patrons on our website or
on patreon and we will get to the phone
lines after Trump's Trump speech the ACE
dot CA the Thea ace dot CA with a twenty
five Canadian dollar super shot today's
biggest super chat you're a wonderful
soul even though I don't always agree
with your positions are you going to be
on the steel man podcast anytime soon I
don't know what that is and I've
certainly not been invited at this point
but I'm always up for considering
podcast appearances for sure Dustin
Brown I know you're often
critical of Alexandria Castillo Cortez
but you have to be encouraged about the
amount of unusual of usually unengaged
people she's getting interested in
politics absolutely
also Generation Z is even more
progressive I did see that report
generation Z indeed is even more
progressive that's true how long do we
have three minutes and 22 seconds let's
see a couple other super chats mira vez
asked about the BuzzFeed story and
Muller's suspiciously specific denial
and how did the BuzzFeed editors
standing a Bayete figure into this I did
um about five or ten minutes on that a
little earlier so I don't want to go
back on to that now but we did touch on
that today black away 54 says your
Pakman with the bleakie a fact he be
shootin a dps gang gang yes I really
couldn't say it any differently myself
Jordan Peterson arrives in the chat is
Trump a cultural Marxist I don't think
so I don't think so
phrenic 32 thoughts on Hasan [ __ ] of
TYT will you ever go on his stream I
like her son I was on his stream not
long ago
he's been carving out a space for
himself alongside twitch streamers like
destiny yeah I like us on and when we
speak privately um nightly he puts me to
bed just like Hannity puts Trump to bed
on the phone no I'm kidding we do we do
speak privately though you know once a
month or something like that cher Mac
how do you deal how to how do you deal
with a OC fans who hate Bernie I'm not
I'm just ignoring that for right now
they're it's irrelevant to how I'm going
to be covering the 2020 primary
saddlebag what's wrong with the YouTube
membership why no can read stuff on your
member sites yeah so saddlebag youtube
membership exists only on youtube if you
want a membership on our website just
get a membership on our website there
are two different things and patreon is
likewise a different thing I want to say
hello to Darren Nevarez and Dylan Starr
who are subscribers 7 & 8 for the stream
okay so we are now just waiting on two
more two more YouTube not YouTube we're
actually doing member website members or
patrons
and I'll open up the phone lines after
the stream okay we've got about a minute
and a half until Trump comes on
supposedly I will remind you that this
program the reason we now are doing so
many live streams today's the 19th of
January and I think this may already be
the eighth stream I've done is because
we're in the new studio thanks to
support from our audience we have all
new lighting we have the best audio and
lighting setup of any time that we've
had we no longer have loud people above
us like at the last studio so now we're
really committing to content for 2019
and to growing that as much as possible
and it's going to depend on the support
of people in the audience so we've got a
couple thousand people on the stream now
I think if just 1% of you I mean when I
talk about we do the show for the 99%
and if 1 percent of our audience
supports us we are extraordinarily well
funded we've got two thousand people
watching right now if just one percent
of 20 go to david pakman.com slash
membership now and sign up even for 3
bucks a month right or 20 bucks for the
entire year which you can do with the
coupon code 2019 we will be so
extraordinarily well supported that the
platforming attacks from the right
attempts to get me fired from Boston
College like we saw from a so-called
activist last month none of that stuff
will matter and that's why I talked
about this is a 1% that that I hope you
will want to be a part of and Mason
Warren is becoming a part of that on
patreon and Nicole Bonior is becoming a
part of that on our website and that
that's all absolutely fantastic stuff so
we're waiting for Trump due to start at
4 o'clock has not yet started I really
hope that the audio works because
sometimes this weird thing happens where
I try to pick up a YouTube stream and
even though the volume is up we don't
hear it so I hope that we will hear that
as soon as as soon as it starts I will
leave the volume up and I think that we
did have a couple of other super chats I
could get to we do
he double-0 1696 David I'm currently 19
and waiting to go into the military I
share a lot of your values and would
love to run for office one day but I
don't really know where or how to get
started any advice I would start local I
would start local because the barriers
to entry will be much lower if you get
involved depending on where you live in
a city council or even on a committee
for the City Council or that there are
just so many ways that you can get
involved at the small level to start
building up your credentials and
networking it's it's I wish it weren't
this way it's not just about the best
people or it's not at all about the best
people it's often about the best
connected people and people who can get
others to help them in their races and
that that would be my advice gb with a 5
dollar super chat saying merely take my
money
jayven with a 5 dollar super chat I make
pretty political music and I think it
helps engage people sometimes I think it
might be kind of like propaganda though
what do you think no I mean listen
fiction commentary shows documentaries
music it's all these are all mediums
that can be used to express artistic
ideas to express political ideas to say
that it's kind of like propaganda I
don't think the medium does not
determine whether something is
propaganda let me say thank you to
Sheryl MacDonald who is a new David
Pakman show member Cheryl thank you I
really appreciate your support let me
also thank Brennan skalitzky who has
signed up using this coupon code wheat
which has led to more than 350 people
becoming members on our web site so far
in 2019
Brennan's skalitzky also using that
really really appreciate that we are
waiting for Donald Trump here we will
open up the phone lines after the more
new members we get the longer the phone
lines will stay open I don't know why
Donald Trump is running late now running
two minutes late maybe oh here we go
what do you say that
Florida says it doesn't make it true
keep in mind I know we're at the table
wanting to do comprehensive immigration
reform last year and for several years
now we believe in border security all
right so maybe we'll turn this down and
just keep it on and monitor it for when
Donald Trump is going to start the
latest news let's take a look at what
the latest news okay this is so the
commentary is not helping us increased
infrastructure investments at ports of
entry Democratic demands advanced
technology to scan for drugs more
immigration judges and customs personnel
yeah that's from Nancy Pelosi and
basically what I what I've been saying
would be fine for Democrats to concede
on it's the wall that is really the
point of disagreement here we're just
waiting for Trump I'll say thanks to
Elizabeth Green Taylor who has signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
Thank You Elizabeth
Blaine Nichols has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership this is
really becoming a very very inspiring
stream a lot of people signing up and
getting on board here I appreciate that
what should we don't know I I'm hesitant
to switch away from the stream because
Trump could start at any minute and if I
turn the audio up and switch it away his
concern for the administration right now
is trying to shore up we're gonna hear
CBS commentary which I don't know that
we necessarily are looking to hear right
now I do have a couple of other super
chats to briefly mention razzamatazz
says thanks for doing this kind of shows
you need more than the previous 22
Norwegian kroner
here's 55 keep it up waiting to hear the
lies from Trump Sam says I'm named after
a prophet so I'll call it Trump's going
to declare and emergency if Donald Trump
does declare an emergency I believe that
at that point this goes beyond simply
evaluating does the deal make sense for
Democrats or doesn't it and it becomes
this is an overt act of propaganda this
is a misuse of the national emergency
mechanism there is no national emergency
we have border crossings decreasing for
the
decade or so we have a net outflow of
immigrants to Mexico rather than in from
Mexico we have the reality from study
after study that immigrants who are
immigrants in general and even
undocumented immigrants commit crime at
lower rates than american-born citizens
which makes absolutely perfect sense
because if you know you're here
illegally you are going to want to stay
under the radar and not even be someone
that law enforcement is aware of so you
can't defend there being a national
emergency period you you simply can okay
we're continuing to wait for Trump I
don't know what's going on I do want to
say thanks to some extraordinary new
supporters a Karen Howard is a new
member
Gary McClinton is a new member and
blowing the $20 $25 super chat out of
the water for today
Joshua Carr is a new $100 per month
patron Joshua thank you for your
extraordinarily generous contribution
thanks to all of these contributions I
will be opening up the phone lines after
after Trump's speech and by the way
sometimes people say David why do you
need people to donate to open the phone
lines it costs us money to run those
phone lines and what some people may not
know is that if we have we basically pay
per person per minute so if we have as
we often do 50 60 or 70 people on hold
if those people are on hold for five
minutes that's 300 minutes of time that
we are paying for so every time I open
up the phone lines and take calls we get
a bill that that we have to pay for and
it can be it can be sort of expensive
okay someone is telling me that I can go
to the White House channel which will
not have commentary let me let me try
that let me see if I can get that set up
White House channel the White House okay
let me go there president Trump okay
yeah so we have that now good advice let
me make sure that this is live live
stream starting soon
we can leave the sound up so that then
we should that's good because then I can
just leave the sound up and then we will
hear Trump when he when he comes on so
that'll be that'll be a good thing so in
that case we can go back to super chats
for now but Redskins fan twenty seven
let's have fun
take a shot for every lie I don't
endorse binge drinking and and I can't
do that
Robert fancy pants motorcycle McGee with
one hundred Argentinian pesos I love
receiving donations and currency from my
home country unfortunately because of
the exchange rate right now I think
that's about two dollars and fifty cents
it is a really really tough economic
situation right now in my birth country
of Argentina
David Krasny says go to the YouTube
White House Channel without commentary
okay we did do that
Timmy Lunsford if Trump does declare a
state of emergency does government
automatically open good question don't
know the answer but I would guess not
Marie Theresa Hughes with a to British
Pound super chap Thomas Higgins is a new
YouTube member and alleycat says living
paycheck to paycheck but still subscribe
to your show signed up a few days ago
keep up the good work
you know Ally I appreciate your support
but I I do get a little bummed out when
I see messages like that because I've
said so many times before
I believe that 5 10 15 20 30 % of our
audience can afford to support what we
do financially the distribution of the
show to satellite television radio of
television stations all of that stuff
and really I do the show so that people
who don't have money to throw around
still have alternatives to whatever
might be provided locally where they
live so I always say if you can't afford
to support what we do without it being a
big deal $1 a month
$5 a month whatever please do it because
there are people who can't and I don't
that's not who I'm trying to get to
support what we do financially and then
I hear from someone like Ally who is not
only a member but is also sending a
super Chad who is living paycheck to
paycheck just imagine if we did have the
full support of everybody who could
easily afford it and then people like
Ally maybe wouldn't wouldn't feel
inclined to do it because they'd say
you're
well funded we don't need to do that but
Ali thank you I really appreciate that
Brian Fagin's is a new member Bob sink
says when does it start father yeah I
don't know
we're just waiting president Trump
delivers his remarks starting thousands
of children are being exploited by
ruthless coyotes and vicious cartels and
gangs one in three women is sexually
assaulted on the dangerous journey north
in fact many loving mothers give their
young daughters birth control pills for
the long journey up to the United States
because they know they may be raped or
sexually a constant or assaulted nearly
50 migrants a day are being referred for
urgent medical care vast quantities of
lethal narcotics are flooding through
our border and into our communities
including meth cocaine heroin and
fentanyl drugs kill 78,000 Americans a
year and cost our society in excess of
700 billion dollars heroin alone kills
300 Americans a week 90% of which comes
across our southern border we can stop
heroin illegal immigration reduces wages
and strains public services the lack of
border day provides provides a gateway
in a very wide and open gateway for
criminals and gang members to enter the
United States same species loading the
criminal aliens who murdered a brave
California police officer only a day
after Christmas I've gotten to know and
love angel moms dads and family who lost
loved ones to people illegally in our
country I want this to end it's got to
end now these are not talking points
these are the heartbreaking realities
that are hurting innocent precious human
beings every single day on both sides of
the border as a candidate for president
I promised I would fix this crisis you
promised Mexico attained the law that
promise one way or the other our
immigration system should be the subject
of pride not a source of shame as it is
all over the world our immigration
system should be the envy of the world
not a symbol of disunity and dysfunction
the good news is these problems can all
be solved but only if we have the
political courage to do what is just and
what is right both sides in Washington
must simply come together listen to each
other put down their armor build trust
reach across the aisle and find
solutions it is time to reclaim our
future from the extreme voices on fear
compromise and demand open borders which
means drugs pouring in human trafficking
and a lot of crime that is why I am here
today to break the logjam here we go and
provide Congress with a path forward to
end the government shutdown and solve
the crisis on the southern border I'm
ready Donny boy if we are successful in
this effort we will then have the best
chance in a very long time at real
bipartisan immigration reform and it
won't stop here it will keep going until
we do it all the proposal I will outline
today is based on first and foremost on
input from our border agents and
homeland security professionals and
professionals they are they know what
they're doing
it is a compassionate response to the
ongoing tragedy on our southern border
in recent weeks we have met with large
numbers of Democrat lawmakers to hear
their ideas and suggestions by
incorporating the priorities of
rank-and-file democrats in our plan we
hope they will offer their enthusiastic
support and I think many will this is a
common-sense compromise both parties
should embrace the radical left can
never control our borders I will never
let it happen walls are not amoral in
fact they are the opposite of immoral
because they will save many lives and
stop drugs from pouring into our country
our plan includes the following 800
million dollars in urgent humanitarian
assistance 805 million dollars for drug
detection technology to help secure our
ports of entry
an additional 2,750 border agents and
law enforcement professionals 75 new
immigration judge teams to reduce the
court backlog of believe-it-or-not
almost 900,000 cases however the whole
concept of having lengthy trials for
anyone who sets one foot in our country
unlawfully must be changed by Congress
it is unsustainable it is ridiculous few
places in the world would even consider
such an impossible nightmare our plan
includes critical measures to protect
migrant children from exploitation and
abuse this includes a new system to
allow Central American miners to apply
for asylum in their home countries and
reform to promote family reunification
for unaccompanied children
thousands of whom wind up on our border
doorstep to physically secure our border
the plan includes 5.7 billion dollars
there is a strategic deployment of
physical barriers or a wall this is not
a 2,000 mile concrete structure from sea
to sea no cathay would cost these are
steel barriers in high priority
locations much of the border is already
protected by natural barriers such as
mountains and water we already have many
miles that don't need the full including
115 miles that we are currently building
or under contract it will be done
quickly our request will add another 230
miles this year in the areas our border
agents most urgently need it will have
an unbelievable impact if we build a
more fully and fully designed
see-through steel barrier on our
southern border the crime rate and drug
problem in our country would be quickly
and greatly reduced some say it could be
cut in half because these criminals drug
smugglers gangs and traffickers do not
stop at our border they permeate
throughout our country and they end up
in some places where you'd least expect
them they go all over our country a
steel barrier running it help us stop
illegal immigration while safely
directing commerce to our lawful ports
of entry
many of these security ideas have been
proposed by Democrats themselves and all
of them have been supported by Democrats
in the past including a physical barrier
wall or fence furthermore in order to
build the trust and goodwill necessary
to begin real immigration reform there
are two more elements to my plan
number one is three years
of legislative relief for 700,000 daca
recipients brought here unlawfully by
their parents at a year's Malcon Xenia
right this extension will give them
access to work permits Social Security
numbers and protection from deportation
most importantly secondly our proposal
provides a three year extension of
temporary protected status or TPS this
means that 300,000 immigrants whose
protective status is facing expiration
will now have three more years of
certainty so that Congress can work on a
larger immigration deal which everybody
wants Republicans and Democrats and our
farmers and vineyards won't be affected
because lawful and regulated entry into
our country will be easy and consistent
that is our plan border security daca
TPS and many other things
straightforward fair reasonable and
common-sense with lots of compromise
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
has pledged to bring this bill to a vote
this week in the United States Senate
our proposal is not intended to solve
all of our immigration challenges this
plan solves the immediate crisis and it
is a horrible crisis it is a
humanitarian crisis like we rarely see
in our country lie and it provides
humanitarian relief delivers real border
security and immediately reopens our
federal government if we are successful
in this effort then we can start the
border project of remaking our
immigration system for the 21st century
once the government is open and we have
made a down payment on border security
and immigration reform starts to happen
I plan to convene weekly bipartisan
meetings at the White House so we can do
a finished product there yeah great
product a product out of having to do
with that elusive immigration problem
whatever we do I can promise you this
yes I will never forget that my first
duty and ultimate loyalty is to you the
American people and it's never gonna
forget it firstly many that's nice our
immigration system will be designed to
improve your lives make your community
safer and make our nation more
prosperous and secure for generations to
come
thank you and God bless america okay
people I guess sort of trying to ask him
questions there okay where to even begin
okay let's so let's see if we can take
this piece by piece the first part of
this speech was the same speech he gave
recently in the Oval Office right
appeals to emotion once again talking
about drugs from Mexico but most of
those are coming through the ports of
entry a wall wouldn't do anything about
that
he again cited this meme about how wages
are being pushed down by undocumented
immigrants the people who are coming
here to work
aren't the actual source of what the
wages are it's the corporations that are
hiring them which go unpunished and
Trump's companies are some of those
right so until there was not even a
mention in this entire abortion of a
speech about what we would do with the
companies hiring undocumented immigrants
that's that's number one that's got to
be the number one priority right then he
talked about how he is going to keep his
promises on this issue the promise was
Mexico would pay for a full wall across
the entire us-mexico
okay don't be tricked into forgetting
that that was the original promised so
then we get to the actual proposal okay
the proposal is Trump wants 800 million
in humanitarian aid what that means we
don't know Trump wants 805 million for
drug detection which again the drug
detection is not really I mean okay if
you're gonna concede that the issue is
at the ports of entry then we might have
something to talk about but he's talking
about drug detention detection as if
it's something coming over the border in
areas that the wall would address he
wants an additional 2758
border agents and law enforcement and 75
new judge teams I thought that they were
for small government okay
this is a massive massive expansion of
government you're 75 judge teams more
courts almost 3,000 new law enforcement
professionals so his solution I guess is
a massive government expansion which
Republicans claim to be against and then
of course he mentions 5.7 billion for
the wall for a steel barrier and now
amazingly he's playing coy saying listen
we don't even need a us-mexico full
border wall did anybody notice how the
goalposts were move and how he
backtracked on this we were told a full
wall that Mexico would pay for now he's
only talking about us paying for it and
he's saying that there's natural
barriers there's rivers there's
mountains there's all sorts of stuff
that's the argument that we've been
making all this time and now he's saying
I just want 5.7 billion for I guess it's
230 miles and that he believes this plan
will cut drugs and people coming in
illegally by 50% literally impossible
okay there is no way a wall could stop
50% of drugs and 50% of people from
coming in when 2/3 of the people aren't
even crossing the physical barrier and
the overwhelming majority of the drugs
aren't crossing anywhere that we would
be putting the wall they're crossing
through ports of entry it's it's an
absolute and total delusion now what is
he willing to compromise on
he is willing to number one do three
years of extended protection for daca
recipients which would get us to 2022
and three years of temporary protected
status extension this is what doesn't
make sense about this this proposal on
the one hand Donald Trump's language is
it would be bad if we deported these
kids it would be bad if people with TPS
or daca status aren't able to get
driver's licenses work permits whatever
well if it's bad and you don't want that
to happen why is it something you're
framing as a concession to the other
side right like if Trump agrees we don't
want to deport daca recipients I
wouldn't do that anyway well then why
are you saying that's what you're
willing to give the other side it makes
absolutely no sense it's an absolutely
ridiculous plan he claims McConnell will
bring it to a vote in the Senate I'm not
sure exactly what what is going to go on
in the house so an absolutely ridiculous
proposal based on appeals to emotion
straight-up lies and all sorts of
distractions and distortions so let me
um let me open up the phone lines
because we've had so many people sign up
for membership and I'll thank some of
those people momentarily I am opening
the phone lines now at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
people can start calling in now and I
will take a bunch of phone calls before
I have to get to the gym I do want to
thank Charles straighter and Michelle
Hall and Michael Richardson as well as
Justin Bane and Daryl Phillips Wow just
a lot of really great inspiring support
thanks to everybody who has signed up to
support including our top supporter of
the stream Joshua Carr who has made $100
a month pledge on patreon the coupon
code still work patreon.com slash David
Pakman show
ww join pakman.com let's kick off the
stream I know I didn't get to you last
time Donte from Florida
Donte you know sometimes you call in and
filibus
though so I'm gonna put you on but I
hope that you're ready to go with with
the topic or question David I'm ready to
go it's a good one cool all right
so it's quick question do you think that
the mainstream media and corporate
Democrats have blown the Trump Russia
story out of proportion for their own
political purposes especially seeing how
they don't pay anywhere near as much
attention to when Trump and other US
presidents have way worse and more
nefarious connections to other foreign
governments what would be an example of
Trump's more concerning than Russia
connections like Donald Trump's business
connections with Saudi Arabia and then
either actually assisting them in a
genocide in Yemen the worst humanitarian
crisis on the planet right now we have
been taught so I disagree with your
premise Dante I mean I have been talking
about that a lot
however there so I think that there is
this talking point that's being spread
which is the real collusion was with
Saudi Arabia no I mean it's it's totally
immoral that we continue to sell Saudi
Arabia all the weapons that we sell it's
completely immoral that we continue to
maintain this relationship given what
they're doing in Yemen I completely am
on board with you but there is no
concerted effort that we have seen to
hide meetings with Saudi Arabia that
Saudi Arabia was providing opposition
research and violation potentially of
the emoluments clause so I've been
covering what you're talking about and I
just don't think it's nearly of the same
scope as what we've seen with Russia
well I'm not saying that it's that the
though that you it's you specifically my
question was about the mainstream media
because it seems that they have a motive
because like I mentioned they don't pay
anywhere near as much attention where
Trump has these other yeah right the
media has corporate media has never paid
enough attention to our immoral
relationship with Saudi Arabia and I'm
completely on board with you with that
critique I just maintain that it's
separate from what's going on with
Russia but also you said that you think
that the rush
yeah I believe that Trump has done gone
way more out of his way to cover up with
the Russia story but I think that's
because it's more focus being paid to
that but the Saudi Arabia situation is
just I face-value objectively it's just
way worse because there's a literal
genocide and he's he's profiting from it
and he is refusing to criticize them
even when they murdered a u.s.
journalist and he's doing it because
he's taking money from the government so
I think that's honestly way worse than
anything I could possibly come out of
what Muller or any of these other many
investigations they're just two
different things I mean one is a
systemic issue related to American
foreign policy with Saudi Arabia which
is an atrocious embarrassment the other
is specific and concerted possibly
criminal actions for the purposes of
winning a particular election so okay
point point made dontay I think we just
maybe don't agree on this let's go to
our next caller from the 401 area code I
think 401 is that's Providence Rhode
Island right yeah is this just me
that is you hey David this is David and
I am indeed in Providence Rhode Island I
get a longtime supporter about it about
a year and a half now Thank You fan
you're welcome my question is regarding
impeachment um do you think that the
house should move to impeach Trump if so
do you think now is the right time or
when would be the right time and what
would it be for work well okay so you'll
get you're kind of running out the issue
which is now is not the right time
because we don't yet know exactly what
it would be for once we know what it
would be for if it's if there are valid
reasons to move for impeachment that
would be the right time to do it so when
you say do I support impeachment right
now I don't because we don't have the
full story at first we need to know what
is the full story of what went down only
when we know that can we evaluate it and
absolutely if if what should happen is
impeachment then I believe that
impeachment proceedings should start but
to say now that impeach
Pietschmann proceedings should start and
the fact that you're asking for what
means now is not yet the right time once
we once it's clear what it would be for
that would be the time to start sure
well my case for moving for impeachment
now would be that we already had
evidence on on violations of the
emoluments call I'm not even squaws and
campaign campaign finance violations as
well so I agree with you the only issue
so here's why I would disagree that now
would be the time
we may get evidence of way way more
serious crimes than that and if so you
don't want to now let the cat out of the
bag with impeachment on those charges
which may not actually get the Senate to
say even if proven this means we should
remove Trump when there may be money
worth stuff coming in the future fair
enough that makes complete sense I only
worry that moas report drops and there's
really nothing incriminating Donald
Trump there and then there's the talking
point of oh well they were waiting for
something to drop for impeachment to
come around but there's nothing here so
now no reason to impeach and that'll be
the argument well we'll have to cross
that bridge when we come to it but I
don't think you can do you know this
pre-emptive impeachment stuff I think is
a mistake thank you I appreciate the
call David great to hear from you let's
go to our caller from the five one three
area code caller from five one three
what's going on that's you hey this is
my second time calling and I think oh
good yes I wanted to talk about the
address that Trump just gave today
please he's not building a wall he's
just building a strategic deployment of
physical barriers come on David right so
you picked up on the semantics games as
well yeah exactly
so I thought I heard him mention
something about hiring more federal
judges is that correct well he said he
wants to do 75 judged teams additional
judge teams yeah do you do you think
something like that might actually like
have a positive effect like I remember
watching a John Oliver segment a while
ago where I talked about how many
undocumented migrants are go on
represented including children and
things
but I think this might actually be yeah
I'm not against that I'm actually for
more of those judge teams the the
problem is that it doesn't have any
place in a negotiation about a wall I
mean again what Trump's talk Trump is so
think about how insane this is on the
one hand Trump and his party want to
shrink government they want small
government and part of what they
proposed in addition to getting billions
of dollars for a wall is 75 additional
judge teams and 2,750 additional border
agents and law enforcement professionals
which number one has no bearing here or
there on the wall but is also a huge
expansion of government I happen to
agree that we need more of those judge
teams but I don't agree that they need
to come as part of a deal to build a
wall mmm yes oh good answer a really
quick follow-up question yeah ladies so
we won't think once again heard Trump
fear-mongering about how illegals are
coming in and raping and murdering
people yeah can we just say at this
point that all Trump supporters are
racist no we can't we can't say that
what but we didn't say that an
increasing majority of them are
indifferent to the fact that Donald
Trump is dog whistling to racists right
so you could be not racist yourself and
say I just really like what he did for
my taxes but I'm indifferent to the fact
that he's dog whistling and in kind of
known racist ways okay thank you
appreciate the call thank you so much
let's go to the 202 area code caller
from 202 go ahead hello in my life
you are live right now okay can the
Democrats force drum to get a
psychiatric assessment and release it to
the public what the president has to
consent to that or would Republicans
have to sign on to it like McConnell and
well Paul Ryan's not there anymore
because he's probably definitely a
sociopath and he is likely demented I
don't know so if you're asking me
legally I don't know what mechanism
would be required to force the President
to undergo a psychiatric evaluation but
it's just not gonna happen unless
something extraordinarily outrageous
like if Trump you know if he starts
yelling at a reporter during an
interview about
eglee aliens right I mean it would have
to be so over the top for any mechanism
to even get bipartisan support that I
don't even think it's worth thinking
about okay and follow-up question what
would the GOP do if impeachment and
conviction happened in the middle of the
campaign for 2020 same procedure if the
candidate died like let's just say it
like August Trump was convicted and he
was removed from office that day they're
led the GOP is like okay we have to go
all pens now do you think that would
have any impact on the campaign yes that
would I think that if Donald Trump were
it were impeached and removed for from
office three months before the election
I think that would have a big impact for
sure and I think the default would be
pence but that I mean it's just it's
such an out-there scenario right now
that you know if something like that
happens it'll be up to Republicans to
figure out what to do it's very
difficult to predict but yeah that would
have a major impact on the 2020 election
yeah I could see that happening all
right thanks have a great day okay thank
you appreciate the call we're taking
calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go to
our caller from the four one nine area
code four one nine what's going on hi
David Thomson Ohio and the Democrats
taking this deal and I think if they
reject it it's gonna get really cheap my
question is if you think Trump declaring
a national emergency it is off the table
and I don't know if it's off the table
but I think that he's going to get so if
Democrats do reject this deal Trump may
have more political fodder short of
declaring a national emergency by saying
look I'm giving them a bunch of stuff
that they want and they're still not
doing it and of course as we analyze the
deal before it's a deal that in a lot of
ways makes no sense but I don't know I I
think that actually this speech and the
possibility of this new I new deal
delays the declaration of a national
emergency if anything okay and I mean
you may have briefly talked about I mean
do you do you ever
rough idea if the Democrats would would
take this killer right are you unsure I
read one report that says Democrats are
not going to take this deal as is but
it's you know it's been 15 minutes so
we'll have to wait and see a little bit
okay thank you thank you appreciate the
call let's go to our caller from the 908
area code we are taking phone calls
because we got a bunch of new members
and patrons on our website thanks to
everybody for their support I have a few
more people to thank momentarily but in
the meantime 908 you're on the air or
maybe maybe you're not 908 are we muted
maybe hello yeah there you are hello
sorry I think you're beautiful oh hi I'm
Brian from new jersey what's going on a
cool question now regarding the speech
but I just wanted to know who do you
think's the most problematic Democratic
candidate that announced like you know
the past few weeks
oh you're saying it this is not related
to the Trump speech you're saying who's
the most problem by ID candidate yeah I
mean I could ask you a question about
the speech I had do have a question but
this will not really wanted to ask you I
don't see any of the candidates so far
as problematic I think that the person
who is most misunderstood as to what who
they are is probably Tulsi Gabbard
you've got some people on the sort of
Leninist left who are kind of rallying
behind her without really understanding
that she's actually more to the right in
some ways and so I think that the one
that's confusing people the most is
Tulsi Gabbard but I don't see any
problematic candidates right now would
you say like Gillibrand meeting with
Wall Street executives maybe hurts her a
lot more or now no problem honestly it
probably doesn't hurt her too much no
I've not done a full deep dive on
Kirsten Gillibrand honestly I think she
just has absolutely no shot whatsoever
so I admit I have not done as much
research into hers as I should but I
will soon and particularly we would get
one or two more candidates will kind of
do an updated full analysis of everybody
who's in so far but now I don't think
that having met with Wall Street
executives is going to be her undoing I
think it'll be the fact that she's just
never going to get her campaign going to
begin with okay okay I think you're
appreciated I joined about two weeks ago
with the 2019 code so oh yeah
would you say membership is better than
Netflix it's a hard hard statement to
make but I have to agree no question
about her aggressive Netflix yes thank
you for the question
thank you appreciate the call and on
that note I do want to thank Wayne lobst
who has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership keep those memberships
coming that coupon code 2019 which gives
you a yearly membership for only $20 and
19 cents it's not gonna be around
forever
okay Jorge Luis has sent a 200 Mexican
peso super chat aside from the deal do
you think it's likely Mulder finds no
collusion and nothing happens yeah I
mean always the most likely scenario was
going to be that there will be no
consequences for what Donald Trump did
for sure Richard hunter mentioned that
the deal should be a bit of wall in
exchange for a pathway to citizenship I
agree and actually mention that before
Michael Cohen will be the John Dean of
the Trump administration says Harvey
willing Shawn Keogh says Wow clinic of
lies No Deal extending daca concedes
that we should help some groups but why
not all also know me constants running
for New York City Public Advocate 226 no
corporate money what are your thoughts
yeah she called me about her race the
other day I didn't I didn't know much
about that position but I'm looking into
it
Joshua Carr the David Pakman show easily
one of the best political shows on the
net glad and proud to be a new patreon
supporter greetings from the UK but
soon-to-be u.s. resident yes Thank You
Joshua between the hundred dollar
patreon pledge and the ten dollar super
chat Joshua is in for about a hundred
and thirteen USD today thank you
didn't senator Graham suggests this a
while ago this so-called deal is garbage
love your content David wish I could
donate more Trump is a master of
controlling the narrative media false
equivalencies and fear tactics whose man
is this get this worm TF out of here
before de ok it's getting a little crazy
in the super chats good morning David
thanks for all your reporting all right
let me go back to the phones let's go to
the 509 area code color from 509 you're
on the air hi David thanks for taking my
call
pleasure so as
I was watching that uh you know little
trafficker oh yeah few things came to my
mind one is I don't think the Democrats
should accept this you know dealer offer
from Trump I agree mostly because if
they do not only Trump gets his bragging
rights about his wall and you know the
undecided voters he'll be seen as like a
great negotiator able to end the
government shutdown bring Democrats to
the table yeah and he gets his wall so I
would say Democrats shouldn't accept
that I agree with your conclusion that
Dems shouldn't accept it although I
disagree that the I I think that if
there was a really good deal on the
table even if it would sort of make
Trump seem to have succeeded that's not
a reason I mean it's sort of playing
it's bad politics it's the worst of
politics to reject a good deal merely
because you don't want the other side to
be able to sort of claim victory the
problem is that this is it what Trump
wouldn't be a good negotiator by virtue
of this deal because remember he said
we're gonna build a full border wall and
Mexico will pay for it now during this
speech he said we don't actually really
need that full border wall because we've
got natural barriers in many places like
rivers and others and I'm just looking
to build 230 miles for 5.7 billion so
even if Trump succeeds it would be
incorrect to say that he has made any
big victory because he's giving up on so
much of what he promised he was going to
accomplish oh yeah I agree completely I
don't think he is a great negotiator at
all especially if Democrats do accept
this deal but I think that too
I don't know an undecided public he
might be seen in 2020 I think you would
hear that home non-stop I got my wall I
ended the government shut down the
government shut down the delayed he
started and ended the government I
totally agree with you he will frame it
that way and that is a political risk
thanks for the call oh great yeah thank
you David keep up the good work no
problem
al she says via super chat if Trump
steel is so fair and full of compromise
couldn't he open government and then
offer it isn't it obvious he's just
using workers as hostages yes he is no
question about it let's go to the 804
area code caller from 8:00
for go ahead hey then d that is you okay
I just wanted to comment first of all
it's hilarious that it seems as though
Trump is continuously struggling to read
yeah I know so that and you can clearly
tell waste of ad-libbing he'll like make
embellishing seriously she'll be like oh
well we need a barrier a really really
really big barrier you know it's not in
there that's exactly right so the the
the the way he does it is he'll be very
robotic
and then he'll ad-lib with just
hyperbole so he'll say we are dealing
with a crisis on the southern border
it's a big crisis folks really big
crisis and you can tell it that's the
ad-lib right which is just talking about
a house how significantly that last
thing he sputtered was this is actually
really beautiful I love watching my my
question is the right continuously gas
can they make up issues just to sort of
sort of try to get they try to get
voters by making up issues that they
don't actually care about like this wall
it started out as a huge wall you have a
proper southern border I was just
barriers and they clearly don't need
they don't want this they don't want the
wall they don't actually need the wall
it's a political movement just Power
Move so what can xi do what do you think
the less could do to sort of use this
and their constant changing perspective
on their own on their own issues what do
you think the left to do to take that
and make that into their own political
power most I don't know because the left
is terrible at what you're describing so
I don't know how they could do it and
you know the truth is that double
standards hypocrisy and shifting
goalposts have become so part and parcel
not only of politics in general but more
acutely of this administration that I
don't know exactly how you take the
obvious failures of this administration
which they try to change expectations
around in order to then present them as
wins like okay Mexico was going to pay
for a 2,000 mile wall now Trump would
consider it
a victory to get five billion of your
money for a 200-mile wall right so it's
oh and and then that now becomes the
standard of victory I don't know how to
turn that against them it does it just
doesn't seem to stick yeah I don't think
the current lefty was prepared to do
that sort of thing
I don't think that they're ready to play
politics the way to come place politics
yeah I don't know he's not at all
uncomfortable with doing illegal things
the plate is politics and to make its
power moves but the Democrats they're
just I don't think they're ready at all
for him I agree there's gonna be a
problem in 2020 thank you for the call I
really appreciate it all right I got to
get to the gym before it gets too late
great for everybody to have joined me
today I am going to be wrapping up at
this point a couple extra thank-yous
Ebru is a new $5 a month patron and we
have had so many great super chats and
all sorts of great stuff and it's just
been an incredible stream I would call
it the best stream ever folks I would I
would actually say that
Dexter lab says special counsel refuting
BuzzFeed for time do me no kohli no idea
what that means but if you're talking
about the Moller statement on the
BuzzFeed story talked about that at the
top of the stream thanks for joining me
I will stream again soon